how's it going ray my name is PewDiePie
welcome back to some more happy with
well basketball Tom zoom with you
happy wheels grabber is the best grass
if I correct them and there is that's
how I roll bechet's that's how I [ __ ]
roll
hell yeah have someone see where my dick
went I got it I got it
hmm gah come on have fun hit the ball
whoa
[ __ ] love this front flip let's go dad
if so see everyone is stunned they're
just [ __ ] frozen that was awesome
alright alright
so first let's go hell yeah what oh oh
yeah oh that's what I would just said
yeah we got hey there we go don't worry
five I got this god damn it there we go
whoa sorry you're like a boss what what
am I doing wrong way no I'm gonna
[ __ ] do this is the last thing I'll
have it there and alright doc but what
does his head does start come on
how's that help possible help what the
[ __ ] I'm that heart
well badass style ballast oh wow a
jacked
Oh No why did I oh well we finished it
puberty sword throw why would you make a
PewDiePie sword throw I don't even play
side throws Beiber burn oh hey there
lady I uh I'll stay there hi hello there
Oh bitte shut what what what is she
doing what are you doing girl that's
what you get for not finishing me oh you
want another one
I penetrate do all night long girl Oh
what is she doing back no bothers my
swords [ __ ] I fine
my life is putt what [ __ ] yeah
you see that [ __ ] Nova nevermind I'm
just kidding
it's all good fun there's a challenge
for me apparently think [ __ ] you pres no
I don't think fast
come on alright let me go ahead oh it
hurts
[ __ ] off Jennifer what what are you
doing there is it alive Jana fine I [ __ ]
it all right far away
you're lucky I survived you little [ __ ]
thank your dad I love you
well I don't love you you pleasure
alright what is this oh no I hate that
ba Mei oh no not the stuff added thank
our shut up ah got dad up what am i
doing I hate my life
let's try this again all right here we
go gentle gentle
excelencia
hard no prop front flap I don't care I
told you I don't care seriously bad
don't do it what what the [ __ ] well [ __ ]
yeah
split ending perfect ending pose right
there Matt or fail oh it's this goody I
already play I [ __ ] it up say hello
that's I got your hand nevermind that is
actually my leg well my leg first type
what is he one [ __ ] cannonball oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
doggy shut up shut up I wanna countable
I said again I'm not I'm gonna make a
yeah best position ever had
nail there or it's like sprays sweet
Aruba
all right front flap it's alright my day
I okay back that but David this is jolly
good weather I try to die shut up I get
up my leg is slapping you keep flapping
him like it's count abuse well you told
me that a million times but I don't give
a shite goddamn it alright hey [ __ ]
dick front flip my bicycle has a tail
well I know I lost my poor little leg
how will life continue after that
fatality my leg I will forever miss your
leg god damn it how are you even talking
Jason sky Go Daddy go that sounds like
mom that rot they go dead don't tell me
watching your house [ __ ] tell you
back oh shut i'm stock ow
god damn it
skip all right he's scared going and we
finish it with our son that's so cute
he stopped dying please see it come oh I
have a plan okay all right now you go
you're like I'll [ __ ] ah you suck bye
I hate you I let me just dance
no I just get on my nipples
[ __ ] it
I'll show you how it's done you little
[ __ ] it let's just do it for the
pastimes [ __ ] alright there we go
what this right in the heaven what is
going what the [ __ ] was that
alright there we go I can do it someone
say something then think so
Brad flem where it's party time now [ __ ]
I sleep leg made it ha what are you guys
just judge your noob
a large Satan eat you a large site and
eats you alright but at least that title
wasn't misleading and how do you survive
this
exactly I got this there we go now I
just got it whoa there we go alright
don't leave me shut your mouth what what
is a dog interpreted him dog game
seriously thank you what the fight what
up what a hell am I supposed donkey tell
me what to do tell me all your secrets
dog gay not there is disgusting alright
huh grab the sirloin tip going grunts
the real gram or is it going Randy you
don't even have a [ __ ] and then we
finish it totally right
what i'm a movin' brofist
brofist all the babies what what the
[ __ ]
what's up for those that all right must
free da ah sorry about that
let me breakfast your buddy we're
actually not to what I don't I don't
care what I did don't grow you drank
again son
sorry Danny I can't borrow fist well
let's get actually Timmy Timmy
shut the [ __ ] up timmy this is only a
demo
ah no I'm so close
[ __ ] off all right thanks for playing
rough ahead all right I'm gonna have to
end sex in here anyway this guy comes
birthday and I'll see you next episode
thank love you Beth [ __ ] you love is our
ain't no potluck a 30-pack party
fist pump you [ __ ] Jersey Shore
[ __ ] Oh No whatever am i popping oh
yeah